[Music]
ian benito welcome everybody
my name is stephanie whitland one of the
mba admissions officers at the stanford
gsb
and i'll be moderating our event this
evening uh during
the next 45 minutes or so
uh we'll have an opportunity to hear
from a wonderful group
of gsb alumni who have joined us for
this evening
they're here to answer your questions so
please be sure to use
the chat feature i'm sorry not the chat
feature the q
and a feature and i will pull questions
from there along the way so thank you
all again for being here
let's get started by welcoming our
alumni panelists who
have generously given their time this
evening to be here today
so i'm going to turn it over let's go in
order
that your name appears on the slide and
if you can just introduce yourself by
sharing your name your class year
and what has been your most
impactful or memorable academic
experience at the gsb
i'll turn it over to alejandra all right
stephanie thank you so good afternoon
everyone
welcome it's a pleasure to be here my
name is alejandro herrera
i am a 2010 graduate
and my most memorable experience at the
gsb
as far as classroom experience was
taking managing growing enterprises with
uh
joel peterson back then so i um i
currently run a manufacturing company
that's a spin-off from a larger company
that took place in 2014
and i've been using what i learned in
joel's class
um almost every day since 2014
it's um it's been a challenge it's fun
but um it is it is by far the
the class i use the most on a daily
basis
thank you
all right this is anna anna garza from
monterey mexico i'm class of 09
and i well i'm doing real estate now and
alejandro stole my line
because i think um i was also thinking
what's my most memorable experience and
i have to say that
uh entrepreneurship related classes like
managing growing enterprises where you
get the chance in a friendly environment
to learn how to
hire fire and deal with you know
scandals and whatnot that
you know at the end when you're running
companies and i i've been managing
and running uh real estate uh bigger
real estate companies and projects right
now well it
it it you you encounter all of these
things in the day-to-day and it's good
to
to have kind of training before you know
being set on
on real life and and managing um
companies and and i think this these
entrepreneurship classes not only
help you if you own a company or run a
company at the end of the day
we are all entrepreneurs in
organizations and we run
you know areas so i think this is very
helpful and impactful
regardless of what you do
thank you anna all right um
i believe diego still hasn't had an
opportunity oh you're there hey hi
thanks for joining i joined the
obviously joined the long
the the wrong zoom link so i was a
participant for a while
um but managed to to find my way to the
room so this did feel a lot like the
first day of the gsb
um so hi everyone i'm i'm devarues um
i'm from mexico city um and then
um i i went to to eat diamond mexico
city and that sort of segues into
my most memorable academic experience
it was interesting that stephanie was
very very clear about it being the
academic experience and not everything
else
because there's some interesting stories
outside of outside of class but
i think uh i think for me i was
coming into the gsp i was very aware of
what the the big classes at the gsb were
was i was not necessarily as aware of
was everything that was outside
gsp and how much freedom the gsb gave
you to go and explore things
uh across the street as they say so um
for me just being exposed to those
those things beyond sort of the classic
realm of business
um things like you know going to the d
school going to the engineering
quad um as well as some of the classes
at the gsp
uh that are not necessarily business
focused but are
sort of go beyond that and allow me to
uh
delve into those interesting
intellectual pursuits um
were super super interesting and super
uh fulfilling and motivating so
happy to chat about that great thanks
diego
all right guillermo everybody
hey my name is i'm from the class of
nba 2013 uh before the gsp
i used to work in chemical manufacturing
now i work in automotive um
one of my most memorable is when i say
mg
as well managing growing enterprises the
formation of new ventures is a really
similar
uh class that really uh you you almost
i mean in every single class you're
talking with uh with with entrepreneurs
with
people of the launch both successful and
and
ventures that were not so successful and
in the end what
it helps you to realize is that the
world is created by people who were not
any uh smarter than you or that
had any more abilities or
things to do it was just uh when you're
willing to do something different
in that and that helps a lot be it uh if
you're an
entrepreneur or entrepreneur it just
helps you to
to lose the fear of doing something
different that the world is created by
people
like us it's not guinnesses that
are working around okay
thank you and uh jesus
hi everyone and my name is jesus but
everybody it calls me chucho so
now you know and i'm originally from
puebla
although i have been working for cemex
for quite a while
and unlike diego i'm not surprised that
stefan is making us this specific
question
because i mean we need to talk about the
academic experience because otherwise
everybody will start talking about
what happens outside of the classrooms
so we need to focus a little bit on the
academics i think
if i have to choose i mean i have a few
that i loved
like for example uh a neuroscience
approach to marketing that literally
blew my mind i mean
you really understand the brain and the
connections that happen inside
and how you can use that science towards
i mean marketing and sales and so forth
but i would say that probably my most um
let's say memorable academic experience
have to do with economics
i'm a mechanical engineer myself and i
have
i mean being considered in many circles
like a glitch in the matrix
alejandro knows me well like i mean for
example i'm the capitalist of my family
and i was the socialist at stanford so i
have
it has always been kind of funny and i
decided to give it a shot and i'm saying
economics because i took
all the economic classes that i could
specifically to
uh come to mind one with accelerated
microeconomics with david krebs
i mean absolutely mind-blowing it's is
literally i mean it's economics for
non-economic and non-financial guys
and at the very accelerated pace and
then that was like
trying to drink water from a fire hose
it was absolutely
challenging the most challenging class i
have ever had
and it really made me feel comfortable
with the generalist that i am
and second i mean together with that one
was the one given by atlas here
he was the senior economic advisor to
the white house for a while
and i mean i took a couple classes with
him but the one that i want to tell you
about is
hr based on economics it's mind-blowing
and
and for a guy once again a mechanical
engineer
i've been trying to put the nuts and
bolts into something that is
being more an art than a science as hr
with basis on economics was out of this
world
so it's i mean i'm just trying to give
you an example that it really made me
feel comfortable as a generalist
and the glitch in the mind in the matrix
that i'm telling you guys
thank you jesus that was great all right
and then we'll finish up with marielle
and then i'll open it up
to the audience to ask some questions
well hello everyone it's a pleasure to
be with you here today
my name is mariel i'm a class of
2016 and i'm from mexico city
i still live in mexico city or came back
to live in mexico city
er my favorite academic experience
i should probably say one of the um
across the street classes
oil prices it finally put an end to the
dream
of becoming like a true chemical
engineer which is what i started when i
was young
and i just um finally understood that
was not going to be my
industry in the future so i have that
one too thank for
at least getting me on the right path
and then
but i think the ones i enjoyed the most
at the gsb
uh actually like jesus were the economic
ones i
i had never had that formation and
seeing
a lot of math applied to very diverse
things like hr
i especially loved atlas years
incentive economics and so i ended up
working at
um on the marketing side of amazon for a
while
in charge of everything deals and
promotions that you see at the amazon
store
and i cannot tell you how much i
remember
at last year talking about incentives
economics and me like explaining to
peers at amazon like how we're gonna use
discounts as part of our strategy to
become an attractive store
for customers to keep coming back and
shop with us
there's a lot of uh interest around the
economics courses it sounds like
it's quite quite the uh professor
so thank you all for sharing so this
first question
is mostly directed to either alejandro
or ana so the two of you can decide if
you want to
both contribute um this
person is calling in from mexico city
and said i'd be very interested
in your views on stanford's
entrepreneurial community
and related academic resources that have
helped you
to achieve your goals i know you want to
go
you start i'll follow um
well i i think i mean that definitely
um the entrepreneurial spirit of
just being in in in silicon valley and
and the type of even even if you're not
um taking entrepreneurship specific
classes you're always exposed to
people who have started businesses
throughout the different classes you
take right so i think
uh for for me uh having
basically guest speakers all the time
coming into exposed cases or giving
you know um more like you know
at what 1pm that we have the general
kind of speakers coming in to talk to
everybody
i think being exposed to that it's very
powerful
um um i i think uh
the as i mentioned entrepreneurship
classes i think the program is very
very good very hands-on but as several
have mentioned
it's not only specific to business but
you can do a lot of
um across across the street classes and
and start really you know there's a lot
of cases of people i i'm not one of them
but
but that developed products or developed
companies doing working with
you know the met the school of medicine
or
you know design and different areas so i
think that's very powerful
and that you get in stanford definitely
the community
in in stanford for me it's it's it
we we might not have the biggest a
alumni network but we definitely have
the strongest one and that's something
that for me
it's it's it's very powerful to have um
people will always answer will always
connect you will always
you know respond to emails so having
those connections
wherever you want to start a business oh
there's always some an alumni that is
willing
to help you or you know open a door or
you know
solve any questions whatever you're
doing so i think that's also as an
entrepreneur having not only the network
within
your class but you know outside in the
alumni network to
to start in any business i personally
think that's very powerful and and i've
had a lot of
cases where i've reached out or it's
reached out to me
and and i think for an entrepreneur um
that is priceless having a very strong
not only class but alumni network and
thank you
thanks so much alejandro anything you
want to add yeah just to follow up i
mean
the school caters to a very broad set of
interests right
you can go in focused on being an
entrepreneur or you can go in with an
idea of entrepreneurship
but but what is true and what at least i
found is
if if you're interested in that
direction
you will have plenty of opportunities to
get involved
um to create to even co-partner
during business school so um as an
example my roommates
two of my roommates built the company
together during business school and sold
it a few years later
um i know three or four classmates um
that were partners at some point in time
during their professional careers post
business school and and just to add that
anna's point
um there are a breath of opportunities
to dive
deep into a specific sector within
entrepreneurship right you want to go
into fintech or
or you want to start something that's
more into renewable energy i took
i took a class across the street in
renewable energy so
um i'm not going to compare to other
schools but being in silicon valley it's
tough to beat
the entrepreneurial atmosphere that
stanford will provide
thank you thanks alejandro all right i'm
gonna
go on to one that i think each of you
can probably contribute in your own way
that you don't
all have to answer it um this is from
tomorrow
and he's asking um
really uh can you tell me how
the gsb helped achieve your professional
goals
and in some cases where some of you had
actually
changed location or industry how you
were able to do that
okay if no one if no one wants to jump
in i can take that
go for it it hustles and
well i mean it's time for i mean yeah
the gsb experience in general has
has helped me professionally every day
since i left i think
it's truly one experience that stretches
all of um your capabilities i mean you
get into a
a let's say a very limited group
in terms of size in which you will find
in people that is fantastic in so many
levels and
guys that are crazy good at things you
never imagined i mean
guys that can make mathematic models
like in
in a napkin that could solve things that
that i mean
could really really invent something new
but at the same time
i mean you you find that there is a
reason why you are part of the group
and uh you you truly can help
within the community improve some of
those aspects that probably those people
are not very good at
and in that and at that sense um as i
was telling you i i
really felt comfortable in my own skin
during my time in strength i have always
been a
sort of a um a apprehensive
type of guy and before i went to school
and
when i was in stanford i learned that
many times failure
is is part of the process of of truly
achieving your goals and
and um that if you don't try
you will never know if you could right
so
probably this is a very simplistic view
but it's one of the most valuable
learnings that i that i
took from stanford so when i brought
that to my own very personal experience
and i learned that
the relevant thing to be successful is
first of all
to make sure that you as a leader are
fulfilling your role properly and are
guiding
those people working with you towards a
shared goal
or an overarching goal right second um
i have changed i mean so many times
from country to country and from
position to position doing
things that i mean range from investor
relations and finance
strategy now commercial development and
one of the things that i that i was
truly transforming strong for this
that i learned how to identify the
strengths in the people
and try to balance out my teams properly
and for me for me in specific
one of my goals professionally was to
help this company that i work in
have a more open approach towards
business
and the more inclusive
uh culture and i think in that sense uh
it has helped me every day since i
graduated
so i could tell you that
probably you can enter with a very fixed
idea but then you identify
that learning along the way is also good
is is
i mean just enjoying your day-to-day
work and just being able to work in many
countries and
and learn from my colleagues in stanford
um it really has allowed me to to
identify the humbleness
that is necessary for a successful team
to
to transcend that's probably i
the two cents that i would try to bring
to the table right now thank you
thank you anyone else have anything to
add
i could do that
um i would add i used stanford dsp
resources for my career right after
graduation
about for the first two years right
after graduation about five times
and so the first time was um
i was i kind of almost fell in love with
a teacher
right so she happened to be the cfo of
oracle and although she was not a
faculty member she taught m a
at stanford i reached out to her
and she got me some of my first
interviews as i was about to leave the
school
um did not end up at oracle in case you
were wondering
and and then it was through
a classmate that i was put in touch with
my first job out of the gsb
it was a private equity firm in menlo
park
and so i was there my first year out of
gsb
then as i decided to explore more
options
and leave my finance life behind
i as an alumni went back to gsb
and used the career office to help me
out
think through what it was that i wanted
to do as i left finance and and
what was the industry i wanted to land
in
they actually helped me reach out to
other alumni
not just from my class to understand the
different options and roles in different
industries and help the law that's one
like that one network is just
absolutely marvelous about they will
answer your emails and your calls
and give you a lot of their time to make
sure you're making a good decision for
yourself
and i am so grateful um and finally it
was through a friend
um i was just doing networking
investigating what was my new industry
and it was one of my classmates from gsb
who was like why don't you call my
brother he's at amazon he
he can talk to you about you know what
does amazon do
and what kind of jobs they have and when
i called his brother um
not only did he explain amazon he
basically pushed me to applying to
amazon and
here i am so those are the different
resources i've used
for amazon to in my first two years out
of the school
you know uh switch industry even get
jobs get two jobs and then
uh switch to industry thanks mario
camera i'll go over to you if you want
to add anything and then i'll
move to another question okay so
so uh building on on these answers is
i would say stanford not only opens up
that horizon
only professionally but also personally
i mean yes i wanted to take classes on
strategy and finance on marketing but i
took classes like
designing happiness where else are you
going to take a class like like that
one class will be called touchy feel
which is about interpersonal dynamics
about
understanding how you how authors
perceive you and how to
to to have honest and meaningful
conversations with them
but at the same time it pushes you to to
realize about
what do you want to get from your life
not only this part of the
the professional stuff which is really
important but also what
do you want to get get outside of that
and that for me what was enlightening my
my my wife used to tell me wait a minute
now you're
somehow we're arguing on a different
level i mean we we
we can you can lead to a resolution you
are communicating better you're
you're talking about emotions feelings
and other stuff that you
i would have never expected to get that
from from from the gsb so what i'm
trying to say is
it is not only that you're getting the
best professional education in the world
but
it also is also helping you to get to
what do you want from the
broader life everything of that
so for that for me that was truly
refreshing truly a surprise and was
worth all the time that i spent there
thank you um open up a question that
really relates to
the experience at the gsb and what the
culture was
like and also things that you were able
to get involved in
outside of the classroom so can anyone
speak
to either clubs or activities or things
that you
um participated in outside the classroom
i can give it a quick shot so i led the
mexico study trip
during my second year so we brought
something like 45 students from all over
the world
to an introduction into our country
one of the best experiences i had during
business school i was part of the
stanford ski club which was not an
official club but we had a blast
i was part of a wine club which was i
think semi-official but we also had a
blast
um but there's there's a lot more stuff
to do
um than you will have time to do
so um i mean half the experience or more
than half the experience it depends who
you ask
happens outside the classroom um and the
most
memorable aspect of your business school
experience
will be the overall package you know
spending time outside class
is is amongst some of the coolest people
you'll ever meet
is in and of itself worthwhile
great thank you thanks alejandro
i i don't know if it's still going on
but back in my days
we used to have the taco nines well the
talks like people
um it's organized by students it's not
something curricular but people
every monday it used to be back then
monday night
somebody from the class would talk about
something very personal right
um it could be part of their life story
something that changed them and i think
and for me being able to listen to my
classmates and get to know them in a
very different perspective it was kind
of like
you know in in an hour you you got to
to to you know know your classmates in a
very different dimension
for you know very different from from
classroom work or or
professionally it was more like a deep
dive into something that really
impacted them or changed them personally
and
you know i i've never heard of that
happening anywhere else in any other
school and i just think the opportunity
of really getting to know somebody
so you know thing you know in a very
deep and personal way
and changes so much because you know
i think you now get to when you see the
person you understand where they're
coming from
and and and it's just such a power and
powerful
a powerful experience to be able to get
to know your classmates in
in in in in different ways but this one
the taco nines or the talks well oh nine
because i'm class of online but from
each class i think it's something that
that was very powerful and i
i i maybe never in a in a lunch at
school or or in
in in you know drinks you would have
never get to go that deep and it was
just an opportunity to get to know
classmates in a very different dimension
that i really value
yeah if i can just sort of add and
expand on that i think
i mean i think i agree with anna i think
talk is the most sort of quintessential
gsp
experience right it's uh 200 people get
together in a room to hear about
somebody else's life stories and
and i think to the original question of
how does how does the vibe look like how
is the experience
for me that was like the most um amazing
thing of the whole two two and a half
years that i was there is
i think part of it is because we're in a
small town and there's not that much to
to do in palo alto to be honest um the
whole community is very
very invested in making sure that the
the community itself is very
entertaining right so
um i mean people do to talks uh
alejandro let the
the study trip it's basically the
student body trying to
create something for the rest of the
student body it feels like
it's like this massive potluck of things
and experiences and clubs and courses
and everybody's bringing something to
the table
and because the the group is so diverse
you literally have like
you know 100 different interests there
so um
for me for me that was like the most
important and the most sort of
heartwarming thing of the whole
experience is it's it's
us entertaining for ourselves and
sharing the things that you care about
and you're passionate about
and you will always find more people who
have like a shared interest
and that was just very very liberating
sorry i i think part of the question was
also about
the culture at school probably all of
these things
show glimpses but i if i may make a
small comment
regarding the culture it has to do with
the level of risk
that we feel comfortable taking during
during the nba and i have the
i mean the blessing of being accepted to
more than one institution and something
that really caught my attention and i
mean from the gsb
was the fact that disclosing your traits
it's i mean it's not a lot i mean unless
you
are really part of the the bottom five
or whatever right
so um as i was telling i mean i
i come in mexico from a culture in which
you are graded in a curve and if you are
i mean
part of the best you can always be
considered
from a cream of the crop
but in stanford i mean i received emails
that
the night prior to the final exams the
sharing notes
from my classmates and that culturally
really blew my mind i mean is
the effort of someone that i barely know
sharing his experiences knowledge and so
forth
so that everybody goes well in the test
that's something that doesn't happen
every day and that
truly invites you to give your best not
only in the classes but in the things
that you will probably have more
experience on the rest
and it truly shaped my life
during the the gsb experience and after
the gsb experience i mean it's
it's something that i think is so
different than other schools in which
you i mean are graded publicly and
compare them
i mean against everybody else and and
you just feel that in the dna of the
class
thank you jesus um
this is for many of all of you are
obviously working
in mexico at the moment can you explain
what that transition might have looked
like
a lot of the folks on the audience today
are curious about what it was like to
return to mexico or how
the stanford jsb helped you to make that
transition back after you graduated
so i did not come back to mexico
right after the gsb i actually stayed in
the bay area for a year working
um and what i did notice be like the
similarity between like myself
other classmates that immediately came
back to mexico
other classmates that went immediately
back to their home countries is
we all sort of had this huge nostalgia
slash hung over from the mba experience
we were used for two years we were like
making the best of every second we had
at the gsb
either going to classes um you know
spending hours deciding which classes
you wanted to take which clubs you were
joining
which of the like five different uh
brown bag lunches were available with
different speakers from around the world
uh what fun activity you were gonna do
which talk you've attended
right and so uh after this very
exhilarating experience
like two years of a lot of you know
pouring
in of knowledge you come back to
the real world and you have to
sort of re-adapt that not everything has
to be
as fast-paced right um
you have to pick up some relationships
where you left them off because um
if if you're not very conscious about
this the gsp can be
all absorbing because it is so high
energy
all the time but i'll let everyone
else jump in about what was their first
few months out of the gsb
like
yeah so so i can i can go with that uh
i mean in a way yeah it's it's it's uh
it's something that you're you're you're
missing like oh yeah there's paradise in
california yeah
uh
in some ways there's there are some ways
to stay connected i mean through the
network i'm a huge sports fan so
uh go with ruin that uh this fall but i
i i follow the
stanford football game i mean the
stanford football uh
team all around so so that's that's fun
to watch
when you're when you're remotely and in
some ways the
the network as well helps a lot uh in
your in your transition i was
i was applying to control things it was
really easy both through my classmates
throughout love night just get a sense
about what was the difference between
the different i mean
uh bcg being mckinsey etc
you get a lot of a lot of support uh to
that and
and and mexico has a really strong
connection to the gsb
uh it is always some prof there's always
some professor
even the dean coming coming here so so
there are a lot of opportunities to stay
connected
uh likewise to the gsb even even
contributing to possessions like this
uh it helps a lot to to keep that
connection strong
thanks caramel
all right anybody else or we'll move on
um one question that i
wanted to ask um just in terms of how
you've grown as a leader were there any
particular
skills that explicitly you learned at
the gsb who that have helped you
in your career so far
yes so so many
i think i think what's interesting is is
you spend two years
as a sponge absorbing a lot of knowledge
and and some of it
you you know it's gonna become useful at
some point but then
two years later you get to this moment
and you're like oh like that's what that
was about like that's what that class
was about and now i know what to do
in this particular situation right um
i think you probably all heard about the
touchy feeling class which i think is
is is super super interesting um
but i think for me there was this other
class called um
i think it was called conversations
management which for me i think gave me
the most sort of tactical
um tactical uh
tips on how to manage a lot of
leadership decisions right and there was
just basically
there was this one line that the
professor used to say is like um
your relationship with people is built
one conversation at a time so don't
don't think that they're easy because
they're actually very complex um
so i think tactically just just being
aware of how
those conversations actually impact your
leadership brand and your style and how
you develop
relationship with people just just was
very very
very eye opening for me and it comes it
comes into use more and more every day i
think
um and obviously i mean just the
the general i think the general sense
that the gsb of like
it's it's it's about people um that just
that just becomes part of your of your
dna right
it's more and more it's not about the
the
technical knowledge and it's more about
knowing how to
think about a team and how to make sure
that people are sort of motivated
engaged and
stores driven by by what they are doing
as part of your team
so so definitely changes you and gives
you a lot of
tools and i think not only tools but
like a spirit of leadership that that i
think was different
for me before those two those two years
were there
adding to that i think this is just a
slogan of stanford of changing lives
changing organizations change the world
it's it's exactly that it's like
the way of of having you know or leading
and having a change in our community and
our in the world is starting with people
right
so as you were mentioning i think it's
just this
very uh you know big focus of people
and impacting people and you know being
effective at that that's what
eventually has the domino effect and i i
think that's very
very empowering and also
maybe not related but for me i think it
was very important
and i don't know if again i'm sorry if i
keep asking if
i'm kind of the older one here in the
group but if the
the like what matters most to you and
why stanford essay like for me
coming in understanding what you're
passionate about
not what you're good at but what you're
passionate about
i think um you know coming into the gsb
understanding where where you're coming
from and what where you want to get
you know but really doing this type of
study um you know
analysis of what's most important to you
i think having that clear once you
join the gsp you you i think you you
take
um all this information and
opportunities in a very different way
um to really empower yourself to to be
able to achieve that as a leader or you
know whatever
maybe tying back to your the question of
your goals
how you know i think understanding what
you're passionate about
and not what you're good at which at the
end it's end up being
it's it's related right you're going to
be good at what you're passionate about
but it's a very different
approach and i think that's very
empowering for
for you know being a good leader and and
and
you know reaching your goals as it was
asked before
thank you did you want to say something
real quick we're getting close to the
end so yes it's it's real quick and i
just want to give you
i mean i mean an idea of the level of of
that
of the classes in the stanford like i
mean i think both diego and i have
mentioned uh the the relevance of the
personal
consciousness and understanding that
leading a group is leading people and so
forth
and i mean you can do that through i
mean the touchy philly class
but also through the leadership labs and
and so many other aspects
but i mean there is also something i
mean there used to be a class
called power i don't know if it's still
there
it really makes you understand
that you are part of like an ecosystem
working in organizations and i mean it
really
makes you try to understand the
connections of the people and
people wanting different things and so
forth so not being
just naive about leading your team but
understanding the dynamics
internally of the organization it's just
important to succeed as a leader
as just being able to transfer your
personal beliefs and your goals to your
team
so i would say like try to be open on
the internal and personal level
but also on the environment in which you
work
is also as relevant and i think i take
those two examples as the combination
that is relevant for a successful leader
coming out of the gsp thank you
that's like a great uh anecdote to end
on
thank you all for your stories that you
shared
and the perspective that you brought to
today's session
i'm sure that many of the
participants will be happy to have heard
from you